foreign
[Music]
Khan a scale customer engineer in emea
and we welcome you back to the technical
guide for startups where we are creating
a series of videos for technical
enablement to start build and grow your
businesses successfully and sustainably
on Google Cloud
in our previous videos we talked about
accelerating model development with
mlops where you learned how to implement
mlops on Google cloud with Solutions
like vertex AI
and today we will be talking about
architecting a retail startup on Google
Cloud
here's what the agenda looks like for
today first we will take a quick look at
what is a typical retail life cycle then
we will discuss how does Google Power
your retail business later we will know
more about how you can accelerate the
retail life cycle with Google further we
will be taking look at an architecture
solving for retail followed by a demo we
will then conclude by showing you how
startup customers are successfully
utilizing different solutions within
Google Cloud to solve for their retail
problems so let's get started
first up we need to understand what the
retail life cycle is and how different
processes contribute to a complete
retail experience
but let's take a closer look at the
retail lifecycle and discuss the six
main stages first along with their
Associated challenges
an entrepreneurial spirit is the
foundation of any retail startup idea it
is a recognition of an opportunity to
fulfill a need or want of customers and
this inspiration and recognition of the
target audience is what drives
entrepreneurs to create new and
Innovative products and services
so naturally the first stage is
logistics and supply chain where the
product is designed manufactured and
delivered to the store
the stage presents challenges like
Inventory management supplier management
and supply chain visibility
next is strategy and planning where
retailers decide on their pricing
marketing and distribution strategies
the challenges here include creating a
competitive strategy understanding
market trends and identifying the right
target audience
merchandising is the stage where
products are displayed in the store and
pricing and promotion strategies are
executed
challenges include selecting the right
products managing inventory levels and
creating appealing displays for products
store operations is a stage where
products are sold and returned if
they're damaged or stolen
challenges include managing inventory
levels optimizing checkout processes and
minimizing loss prevention
marketing is the stage which retailers
promote their products to customers
challenges include creating compelling
marketing campaigns identifying the
right channels and tracking Roi and
finally we have customer experience
where customers interact with the
product
challenges include creating a shopping
experience providing exceptional
customer service and managing returns
and exchanges
by understanding and addressing the
challenges associated with each stage of
the retail lifecycle retailers can
improve their operations enhance the
customer experience and ultimately Drive
sales and growth the covid-19 pandemic
has accelerated the growth of e-commerce
by four to six years
leading to a rapid shift in the world of
omnichannel retail this shift has
resulted in an explosion of data across
multiple business functions including
advertising data supply chain data
pricing Data customer loyalty and much
more
as more retail activity takes place
online the amount of data being
generated is growing at an unprecedented
rate
retailers now who have access to a
wealth of data that can help them make
Better Business decisions but they must
also find ways to effectively manage and
analyze this data however managing all
of this data can be challenging
retailers must invest in the right tools
and Technology to ensure that they can
effectively manage and analyze this data
by doing so they can gain valuable
insights that can help them stay ahead
of the competition by doing so they can
gain valuable insights that can help
them stay ahead of the competition even
in the midst of a rapidly shifting
Retail Landscape
in today's Retail Landscape data is more
important than ever before retailers who
use data effectively can optimize
Logistics fulfillment and delivery
improve merchandising and assortment
streamline store operations enhance the
omnichannel experience for their
customers and improve customer
acquisition and retention
by leveraging data retailers can get
insights into their customers
preferences and behaviors which can help
them personalize their shopping
experience and build stronger
relationships with their customers while
identifying key customer Relationships
by utilizing third-party data streams
they can also use data to optimize their
supply chain and inventory management
ensuring that they always have the right
products in stock
additionally data can help retailers
improve their Logistics and delivery
processes ensuring that orders are
fulfilled quickly and accurately and by
analyzing data on store operations
retailers can identify opportunities to
streamline processes and reduce costs
overall data is a key driver of digital
transformation for retailers helping
them to stay competitive and meet the
changing needs of their customers in
today's rapidly evolving Retail
Landscape let's take a quick look at how
does Google Power your retail business
as the industry transitions into the new
normal it's really important to have the
right partner in this journey Google for
retail is a complete set of retail
specific Solutions across one Google
ready to use AI tools that you can use
without building from scratch
from consumer products like Google Maps
assistant and Google search to
Enterprise great products like Google
analytics Google workspace and ads Etc
we believe in transforming your business
by applying technology from across
Google our products help enhance
productivity and collaboration by
enabling everyone from store associates
to HQ teams to drive Innovation for you
Google Cloud's retail capabilities span
across key areas such as customer
experience associate or employee
experience supply chain and
sustainability store modernization and
Enterprise infrastructure modernization
in partnership with Google retailers
benefit from a cloud platform that is
strategically Allied to the industry
with Executives coming from Deep retail
industry backgrounds driving decisions
and solutions
retailers gets access to the same
technology and infrastructure that power
Google's many diverse platforms such as
search YouTube Maps Etc in a nutshell
the best of Google's Ai and ml expertise
and Engineering power
we are operating the cleanest cloud in
the industry a key initiative that can
help align value with our customers we
have eliminated all of our carbon
Footprints since our founding in 1998 a
first of any company our size we have
matched a hundred percent of our
electricity consumption with renewable
energy purchases since 2017 which
includes the electricity to power Google
Cloud
consumers are engaging with Google
across a multitude of platforms to start
research and complete their shopping
Journeys by collaborating with Google
you can lean into this data and this one
Google expertise
we give you access to the same
technology that we are known for imagine
the searches views and volume of data
and users that happen every day we use
the same infrastructure expertise for
you with that said let's talk about how
you can accelerate the retail lifecycle
with the help of Google Cloud
as a business continues to gather vast
amounts of data it becomes increasingly
important to have a platform that can
make sense of this information and
provide useful insights Google Cloud
enables data modernization by connecting
data under one platform to power
omnichannel insights for example data
flow connects your business and
disparate data with bigquery allowing
multiple silos to integrate to a single
warehouse and analytics engine
this way retailers can power omnichannel
insights and end-to-end business
intelligence to optimize each stage of
the retail lifecycle
one of the primary areas where these
insights can be useful is in marketing
and media
by utilizing Google Cloud's platform
marketeers can help optimize their
marketing spend ensuring that they are
reaching their target audience and
getting the most out of their
advertising budget
merchandising and planning is another
area where these insights can be
incredibly valuable
with the help of Predictive Analytics
businesses can make better assortment
decisions ensuring that they have the
right products in stock at the right
time
by connecting data under one platform
Google Cloud helps enable businesses to
gain a more comprehensive understanding
of their operations this understanding
can lead to better decision making and
ultimately improved performance as
businesses continue to grow the amount
of customer data they collect can
increase exponentially however this data
is often stored in various data silos
making it difficult for organizations to
gain a holistic view of their customers
this is where Google Cloud can help
Google Cloud allows you to break down
data silos and bring all your customer
data together in a single place creating
a customer data platform
this platform helps enable you to
visualize and share real-time insights
across your organization helping you to
personalize marketing and customer
experiences
bringing data together from various data
silos is just the first step of your
data Journey
once all this data is together in a
single place you need to transform it to
be ready for analysis and run analysis
to generate relevant insights from it
this is where Google Cloud's data
transformation and analytics tools come
in handy
by using Google Cloud's tools you can
generate valuable insights that help you
create better experiences for your
customers
Additionally you can activate those
insights across your organization
helping you to make better decisions and
drive better results
[Music]
using Google Cloud Technologies to
Institute a customer data platform can
help your organization to break down
data silos gain a holistic view of your
customers visualize and share real-time
insights personalized marketing and
customer experiences while generating
relevant insights and activating those
insights across your organization retail
analytics is crucial for retailers to
gain insights into customer Behavior
sales performance inventory management
and more looker provides retailers with
the tools to power a multitude of data
experiences from Modern business
intelligence and embedded analytics to
workflow Integrations and custom data
apps
looker is a powerful data visualization
and analytics platform that enables
retailers to create unique data
experiences for Next Level business
analytics with looker you can create
integrated end-to-end data
visualizations that give you a complete
picture of your business performance you
can also create customizable data
experiences that can be used anywhere
allowing you to access and analyze data
from any device
looker uses bigquery for data querying
enabling modern bi and analytics ml
powered insights data-driven workflows
and custom applications this means that
retailers can query vast amounts of data
quickly and easily generate insights and
predictive models and use those insights
to optimize business performance
Lookers ml powered insights enable
retailers to leverage machine learning
to automatically detect patterns and
Trends in their data these insights help
retailers to optimize your marketing
campaigns pricing strategies and
inventory management
in addition looker enables retailers to
create data-driven workflows automating
data collection analysis and Reporting
this allows retailers to save time and
focus on driving business results
finally looker enables retailers to
create custom applications that meet
their specific needs these applications
can be embedded into existing workflows
providing retailers with the tools they
need to succeed
let's talk about demand forecasting with
Vortex AI on Google cloud and how to
improve your supply chain planning and
optimized purchasing and Merchandising
as you know demand forecasting is the
process of predicting future demand for
a product or service it's a critical
part of any business as it helps you
ensure that you have the right products
in stock at the right time but demand
forecasting can be a complex and time
consuming process
that's where Google Cloud comes in with
Google Cloud you can use vertex AI to
help automate and improve your demand
forecasting process
Vortex AI is a suite of machine learning
tools that can be used to build and
deploy machine learning models for a
variety of tasks including demand
forecasting
what x AI forecasting is a powerful tool
that can help you improve your demand
forecasting accuracy significantly
it does this by automatically processing
your data and evaluating hundreds of
different model architectures
what xci forecasting also makes it easy
to deploy your models and get
predictions
so if you're looking for a way to
improve your demand forecasting Google
cloud is a great option with vertex AI
forecasting you can automate and improve
your process and get more accurate
predictions Google Cloud can help you
improve your merchandising Decisions by
providing insights into which products
are selling well and which products are
not this can help you place products in
the right locations and promote them in
the right way
modernizing the digital Commerce
experience with Google Cloud helps
enable
reflectations and help increase Revenue
across their digital properties
our customers can innovate quickly by
engaging with us in a model that works
best for them from building your own
platform on Google Cloud directly to
working with one of our partners or any
out of the box options
within all these options you will unlock
scalability reliability and security
needed to deliver always on personalized
experiences for your Shoppers the goal
is to enable retailers to offer always
on digital Commerce experiences making
discoverability and purchasing products
a frictionless experience for their
customers
with additional Solutions available on
Google Cloud such as Vision product
search recommendations Ai and Retail
search retailers can offer a better
customer experience that drives
conversion and revenue growth
due to ever increasing customer
expectations retailers now have to
reimagine adopt and transform all parts
of their businesses to stay competitive
apigee helps solve the problem raised by
inconsistencies across multiple channels
within retail by handling mediation for
API traffic across all channels offering
a standardized API interface to the
consuming applications and partners
while decoupling those digital touch
points from the retailers back-end
systems
this helps drive speed to Market by
allowing rapid changes to both front and
back-end systems the right policies can
be applied to all the API traffic such
as
rate limiting quotas or the
authentication and authorization of
client systems and end users Rich
visibility established for monitoring
and Reporting how apis are being
consumed retailers using apogee are
focused on ensuring a consistent
experience by making data digital
capabilities available as apis that are
leveraged across all the channels this
means having consistent assortment
consistent inventory and availability
consistent pricing and having the same
set of capabilities at each digital
touch point
Frontline workers form the backbone of
your company they are often the first
people customers connect with the people
who build the products welcome the
customers fulfill the order or answer
their service call with a large
Workforce and high turnover retail
operators have a lot to manage but you
can keep the focus on customers by
empowering your Associates with Google
workspace Frontline Behind the Scenes
you can easily use Google workspace
Frontline to streamline onboarding and
training for your employees on ground by
using drive to upload launch videos
campaigns promotions Etc simply use it
to manage everything with ease whether
it's to audit ongoing emails or Pia data
in Gmail use forms to digitize product
recalls time of requests supplier orders
Etc or simply create a dynamic schedule
using sheets and calendar together to
assign tasks Google workspace Frontline
gives the retail Frontline workers what
they need to get the work done all in
one place it enables people to move
between chat video calling and content
basically everything they need to get
the work done on the move over the last
two years we have helped our customers
around the world to meet the demands and
needs of their contact centers from 24 7
self-service with virtual agents to
reducing average handling time and
increasing csat with our agent assist to
analytics that scaled with insights
every industry and every moment we help
across all channels by providing a
unified platform to build on at the core
of our conversational AI is technology
that helps enable a conversation with a
machine that is as good as a human
interaction
for an example speech to text speech
recognition understands what customers
are saying regardless of how they phrase
things what vocabulary they use or what
accent they have Text-to-Speech allows
us to respond to the customers in a
natural human-like manner that pushes
the conversation along
and then dialogue floor understands a
customer's intent and determines the
appropriate Next Step
sap on Google Cloud can help retailers
power Next Level intelligent operations
with flexibility and scalability of the
cloud most Enterprise data sits in sap
While most operational and iot data sits
in siled systems
so by operating sap on Google Cloud you
can connect your data processes and
equipments to power more intelligent
business operations
which means you can unify data from sap
sales and marketing systems and multiple
external sources on Google Cloud to
uncover analyze and democratize insights
with bigquery and data q a
or leverage Google's AIML to harness sap
data and fuel use cases from Vision AI
to Dynamic pricing or simply get ml
empowered Data Insights through combing
sap and bigquery data lakes with
self-service smart analytics based on
lookup flexibility control and manage
your operations on Google clouds secure
scalable and open infrastructure
by using solver empower the planning
optimizers of sap ibp with continuous
operational optimization capabilities to
have an end-to-end visibility in retail
business we need to have a digital
representation of the physical supply
chain in a digital world think about the
amount of data that is available it's
huge and there are always going to be
challenges with that data you can
digitize it but you have to be able to
operate knowing that it's not going to
be 100 clean the key is layering
Intelligence on top of it which allows
you to work with perfect and imperfect
data both Supply chains are really
complex there are a lot of different
players involved we need to be able to
operate within and within ecosystem of
Partners isvs system integrators
Etc by operating with them we can bring
more success in the supply chain world
now the question is how do we make this
happen
we want to leverage tools that are
available to make their supply chain
more applicable Google Cloud's digital
supply chain twin is designed to help
businesses manage their supply chain
it uses real-time data to create a
virtual representation of the supply
chain which further than can be used to
make decision about inventory Logistics
and transportation the dsct also help
businesses identify and address
potential problems in the supply chain
it starts with retailers data all your
information about your products sales
catalog information and marketing even
seasonal events and proportional
information and further information
about stores and distribution centers
depending on what you want to predict
for the information is then used to
create your forecast only
you can then utilize Google's
proprietary ml models available through
vertex AI which are specifically
designed for demand forecasting for many
businesses data science team and
business planner function in separate
lanes and when you're using
sophisticated modeling techniques it can
be hard for business users to learn and
Trust data science forecast with
explainable AI and local bi tools we are
making it easier to bridge this Gap so
that business planners can easily
compare our recommendation with forecast
based on their previous approaches
understand influencing factors and also
be able to do better post forecast
analysis and evaluation so you know what
net revenue impact you have managing
applications across Cloud environments
can be challenging and complex enthos
Google Cloud's new open platform lets
you run an application anywhere simply
flexibly and securely embracing Open
Standards supports running applications
unmodified on either an existing
on-premises Hardware Investments or in
the public cloud
anthos is a 100 software based solution
which means you can get your
applications up and running on your
existing Hardware with no Force stack
refresh and post leverages open apis
which gives you the freedom to modernize
your applications at any place anytime
and at your own pace
now because enthus is based on gke which
is Google's kubernetes engine you
automatically get all the latest
features and security patches without
having to do anything yourself
anthon Springs Google expertise and
knowledge in application modernization
and management to our customers anthos
is one consistent platform to modernize
Legacy applications and build new ones
in a hybrid and multi-cloud environment
you can ultimately use enthos to move
faster and to connect your Enterprise
technology with your business operations
removing the cumbersome and time
consuming management of applications
that typically occurs across Legacy
systems or multi-cloud environments
Google product Discovery Solutions bring
expertise flexibility personalization
and Innovation to your digital shopping
experiences for example you can simply
benefit from Google's advanced search
capabilities to provide Google quality
search that is configurable to meet your
end user needs
or simply perform scale at search by
leveraging users shopping history to
enhance shopping experiences and
increase your conversion
now you can better understand your
Shoppers search intent and context to
provide high quality search results to
find products on e-commerce websites and
mobile application
with Google Cloud recommendations AI
retailers can deliver highly
personalized product recommendations at
scale or simply use Google Cloud's
Vision to engage customers by enabling
your customers to shop based on visual
images and more
so to sum it all up Google Cloud brings
unique advantages as a cloud platform
these advantages include speed scale and
adaptability we enable exceptional
digital experiences during Peak shopping
periods without sacrificing performance
or reliability
we provide premium support experiences
to help reduce customer anxiety and
share operational fade by collaborating
closely with your engineering teams
culture of innovation
our retail experts work side by side
video teams to solve your biggest
challenges in unique ways access to
Google Cloud's engineering analytics and
security Talent helps Drive Innovation
throughout your organization
highest quality AI enamel are Advanced
embedded artificial intelligence and
machine learning capabilities help you
optimize product assortment improve
Supply chains and drive Customer Loyalty
across the retail value chain
utilize Google products integrate with
YouTube shopping gpay Google assistant
and maps to better serve your customers
online and in store while increasing
engagement and conversions
end-to-end security you own your data we
will never use it for any purpose other
than those necessary to fulfill our
contractual or legal obligations we
offer industry-leading controls to
prevent unauthorized access to your data
committed to openness and choice
our multi-cloud and open source
Solutions protect your business from
vendor login only pay for what you use
and benefit from average savings of up
to 57 on workloads which is
automatically applied based on monthly
usage and by prepaying for resources at
discounted rates a huge Advantage for
managing peak season shopping events
here is a simple architecture for an ETL
export transform load pipeline using
Google Cloud to ingest your business's
data from various sources and then
utilize it in enriched data experiences
so on the left side of the architecture
you ingest business data from sources
like Google ads YouTube ads Google
analytics for your retail website and
much more
this data then is ingested into a data
Lake in Google Cloud Storage in various
formats from here onwards we utilize
data flow to transform this data for
ingestion into our data warehouse
so data flow is a fully managed
streaming analytics service that
minimizes latency processing time and
cost through Auto scaling and batch
processing
once data is transformed it is moved
into bigquery which is a serverless cost
effective and multi-cloud data warehouse
designed to help you turn Big Data into
valuable business insights
great so now that we've Consolidated
data from multiple sources into bigquery
we have a plethora of options on how to
utilize this data to enhance our retail
startups operational workflows in a data
driven manner
for instance we can utilize looker which
is a business intelligence software and
big data analytics platform that helps
you explore analyze and share real-time
business analytics easily
you create modern bi and analytics
solutions from our business data or we
can use this data for integrated
insights and Reporting
data-driven workflows for instance mlai
workflows such as forecasting or dynamic
real-time alerting to enable you to take
more informed decisions in lesser time
and finally to utilize this data in your
retail applications or websites to
provide experience like tailored
recommendations or faster and more
secure checkout for your customers
now let's look at a demo of building an
e-commerce recommendation system by
using bigquery ml for this Demo's
reference we are using a sample Google
analytics data set which is available
publicly in our documentation as well so
let's start first by creating a new data
set and for that open the bigquery page
in Google Cloud console in the Explorer
panel select the project where you want
to create the data set expand the
actions option and click on create data
set
on the create data set page for dataset
ID type the name of the data set that
you want to use for this Demo's
reference we are using the name bqml
for data location choose whatever
location is closest to you and then
click create data set once the data set
is created in the query editor pane you
run a SQL statement to copy a subset of
the Google analytics sample data into a
new table and then populate the client
ID field which you will use as the key
to aggregate implicit user feedback in
the next step
run the SQL statement to create a table
containing the training data run the
version that uses client ID field as the
key if you plan to export data to
Analytics 360. run the version that uses
full visited ID field as the key if you
plan to use the data with other
Marketing Systems
then run the create model SQL statement
to create train and deploy The Matrix
factorization model
after training completes the trained
model is deployed as bqml dot retailer
underscore recommender
use the ml dot recommend SQL function to
get predictions from the deploybq ml dot
retail underscore recommender model
run the SQL statement to get the top 5
prediction for all of your users
this generates generally a large amount
of rows so this output is first written
to a table and then the 10 records are
retrieved so you can see an example of
the data
after you have the recommendations how
you make them available to your
production pipeline depends heavily on
your use case you can either use a bi
tool like looker for further analysis or
simply explore the data more by
downloading in CSP format to a cloud
storage bucket for this Demo's reference
we have used looker for exploring the
data further by simply clicking the
option explore with local Studio
and once the data is in record Studio
you can further explore your data by
using interactive dashboards and reports
that Inspire smarter business decisions
with that we end our demo time to look
into customer success stories together
Lush migrated its Global e-commerce site
to Google cloud in 22 days
significantly improving their
reliability and stability of its site
Auto scaling allows Lush to
automatically scale its infrastructure
up or down to meet demand which helps to
improve availability during Peak loads
migrating to Google cloud has helped
Lush to reduce its infrastructure costs
by up to 40 percent
Google's high quality private network
has helped Lush to streamline its data
center usage from 5 down to three Lush
handles its first Boxing Day with no
instability or outages thanks to its
migration to Google Cloud
want to know where to learn more about
Google Cloud's retail Solutions scan the
QR code or click the link in
descriptions to learn more as a first
step you can learn more about how Google
Cloud AI Solutions can help you leverage
business intelligence second you can
learn more about featured products for
the retail industry and how our
customers are using them you can also
talk with an expert by reaching out to
our Solutions engineers and finally you
can look into how our partners can
support you on your Google Cloud Journey
coming up in our next session we will be
covering modern Isaac with anthos hybrid
connectivity networking followed by a
deep dive into architecting a healthcare
and Life Sciences startup with Google
cloud and then moving forward towards
the end of grow series with a rap video
of grow series and what we have covered
in the journey and that's a wrap don't
forget to like And subscribe to our
YouTube channel and click on the Bell
icon below to get notified each time a
new video is posted
thank you and stay tuned for our next
video
[Music]